there are a couple dudes where I've been
like your is so big that like this
actually wouldn't be a good time for me
and I think there's something cool about
being like I can't I can't it's too much
too big he too big as opposed to being
like throw in or like having to like
build them up like having to be like no
it's okay and okay imagine let's do a
demonstration okay imagine I'm the man
and I have a micro penis okay like
imagine if I put my penis in in you and
even though it's I could feel it and
even though it's really tiny I'm just
like
just there's things like just look at my
hips and what I'm doing like m is koala
is he the same size The Way She Moves so
slowly and she's like just imagine I'm
the man he's like a regular siiz man the
way she approached so gently it was like
a baby koala